la parole est à monsieur gérard cherpion
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre
depuis quatre ans vous grandissiez le
dialogue social comme un étendard de la
gauche
cette gauche qui serait la seule à
respecter les partenaires sociaux nous
venons pourtant d'apprendre qu'une
organisation syndicale allait poursuivre
le gouvernement justice pour non-respect
de l'article l
1 du code du travail que nous avons
votée en 2007
sur proposition de gérard larcher une
première dans l'histoire de notre pays
en effet cet article oblige gouvernement
a consulté les partenaires sociaux
lorsqu'ils proposent un projet de loi
sociale or dans un courrier adressé hier
au gouvernement
force ouvrière dénonce preuves à l'appui
votre attitude et vos mensonges
ainsi vous ne les avez pas consultés sur
le projet de loi ni même transmis un
document d'orientation ainsi que nous
n'ont d'ailleurs confirmé des autres
partenaires sociaux suite aux fuites
dans la presse de votre projet de loi
vous avez été contraint de retarder sa
présentation pour enfin consulter dans
la précipitation les partenaires sociaux
vous avez ainsi vous même admis que
cette obligation légale n'avait pas été
respectée pendant que la contestation ne
cesse de grandir dans la rue et dans
votre majorité
ce dernier épisode est un coup dur à
coup de grâce pour votre projet de loi
alors que ce texte vous faites ouvrir
une fenêtre vers plus de flexibilité
pour l'entreprise de sécurisation de
l'emploi pour le salarié en renforçant
dialogue social elle déclinera au final
qu'un nouveau chapitre à vos renoncement
et à votre incapacité à réformer le pays
monsieur le premier ministre la loi
travail va-t-elle subir le même sort que
celle de la déchéance de nationalité
le gouvernement va-t-il être condamné
par la justice pour non respect du droit
et par là même des partenaires sociaux
avant même l'examen du texte au
parlement
merci la parole est à madame myriam mal
comme remy nice du travail dans l'emploi
de la formation professionnelle et du
dialogue social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
gérard cherpion
je m'étonne de votre question j'ai eu
l'occasion
lors de la commission aux affaires
sociales de vous dire précisément ce
qu'il en est de l'article l
et je tiens ici à vous le rappeler une
semaine après ma nomination à ce poste
jean denis combrexelle nous a remis son
rapport au premier ministre et à moi
même
à partir de là nous avons proposé nous
avons demandé aux différents partenaires
sociaux s'ils souhaitaient ouvrir une
négociation
ils ne l'ont pas souhaité et c'est pour
cela que nous avons fait de nombreuses
consultations
je ne méconnais pas l'article est là
sachez que s'agissant du compte
personnel d'activité là où au moment de
la conférence sociale
il y à une acceptation d'ouvrir une
négociation
nous avons par la suite envoyé un
document d'orientation conformément à la
loi
est ce que je dis est tellement vrai que
le conseil d'état a validé dans l'examen
de ce projet de loi et a bien dit que
l'ensemble des procédures avaient été
respectées mais je vous remercie
monsieur le député cherpion de rappeler
que depuis 2012
en effet nous avons renforcé la
démocratie sociale dans notre pays alors
même que certains de vos pores de votre
bord politique demandent la fin du
paritarisme alors même que certains dans
votre bord politique refuse le dialogue
social demande la mise en oeuvre des
référendums à la main de l'employeur
c'est cette réalité là donc je m'étonne
qu'aujourd'hui vous me fassiez justement
le porte parole d'un des syndicats
kim a en effet adressé un courrier et je
vous rassure ce poids j'ai l'habitude de
répondre à mes courriers également et
monsieur mailly aura une réponse
officielle de ma part au-delà de ça et
je crois que c'est essentiel vous nous
dites aujourd'hui que cette loi était
vidé de son contenu
moi j'étais en commission des affaires
sociales je trouve que les témoignages
sur la loi sont suffisamment savoureux
quelque part ça montre qu'on a trouvé un
très bon compromis
je vous remercie merci la parole le père
madame note